[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
oh the distractions
distractions distractions distractions
everywhere
you must keep your eye on the ball you
must keep your eye on the prize you must
know what is important that is why you
come here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and simulcasting to the books of face
hello everyone out there on Facebook
listen there's a lot of distraction
going on this morning and really the
last few weeks
and the reason why is because there's
always an October surprise you've heard
these phrases before
and we're starting to see the October
surprises uh being dropped on
Republicans and they're really upset
they're really upset about politics
and how elections work
particularly Lindsey Graham
but they don't have any October
surprises
so they're trying to use the media to
distract
from the real issue
that they the Republican Party the
America First Nazi party wants to take
away your rights they want to turn this
country into a fascist state
they're running on it they're going to
shut down the government they're going
to have a National Abortion ban
they're going to make sure women do not
have rights they want to take away your
voting rights
they want to take away the consent
of parents from their children I'm dead
serious I'm not [ __ ] you you're my
favorite turd I wouldn't do that
I've been saying it for a long time I've
been telling you hey they want to take
you
as a parent your consent away from your
from your children
and it all it all focuses around
a marginalized group
trans children
they have identity crisis
or they're seeking help because they do
have an identity crisis something's
going on in their life
and they're going to use those
marginalized groups of people to take
away your consent
I'm telling you this I've been saying it
I've been yelling it and screaming into
this [ __ ] microphone
it's time
and the polls are tightening that's
another distraction do not pay attention
to these [ __ ] polls
they're nonsense
you are the pole you are the one who
makes it happen
regardless of what the polls say Stacy
Abrams is down oh Warnock Warnock is
close they're closing in on Warnock
who gives a rat's ass what these
Antiquated polls say who gives a [ __ ]
the only time I want you to listen to a
poll is if it motivates you to go vote
that's it
if you look at a poll or you hear some
[ __ ] nonsense on the mainstream media
and they're like oh
Herschel Walker closing in on Warnock
and and it makes you not want to vote
stop listening stop it
this is no time to relent this is no
time
to get complacent
now is the time to lean in
yesterday was the last day in Texas
to check your registration to make sure
you're registered to vote it was the
last day if you're in Texas and you're
not registered you're not voting
and if you're in others in other states
as well
and you're going to see the distractions
the distractions the distractions
be deployed here
over and over and over again they're
distracting veteran veteran needs closed
captioning
because he has to have closed captioning
to read so that he can give you a
coherent answer you people really you
people really are [ __ ] dumb he is the
sitting lieutenant governor
of Pennsylvania
he's running against a [ __ ] puppy
killer from New Jersey not even from
Pennsylvania who is a Dallas Cowboys fan
I'm sure pennsylvanians will love that
about Dr Oz he's a Dallas Cowboys fan
he's not you you he's not you
fetterman is you regardless if he has to
read to make sure he understands what
he's hearing because he had a massive
stroke listen liberalism is strong and
the perfect example of how strong
liberalism is is John Federman
after a stroke he could have just bowed
out it almost killed him he could have
quit
he could have said there's no way I can
do this no [ __ ] way can I overcome
this
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's it's the
heart and the fight of Pennsylvania
inside fetterman
advancing his campaign and the media is
like oh what you need you need to read
you need to read
he had a stroke that almost killed him
dudes walking around dudes campaigning
all over Pennsylvania dudes doing
interviews with you dumb [ __ ]
I'm talking to the media here
oh well is the do the people of
Pennsylvania deserve to know they're
looking at it what are you talking about
you think the people of Pennsylvania are
dumb they could see fettermen walking
around talking doing interviews going
before crowds
still being the lieutenant governor by
the way
it's all a distraction
I'm telling you it's all a distraction
you must not relent you must lean in
don't listen to the naysayers in the
media and you're like Tony yeah but I
don't give a [ __ ]
it just takes one little whiff one
little whiff
of you in your community
that it's it's over they're gonna lose
Democrats are gonna lose
that's all it takes for one person to
tell another person and another person
and this person and it starts to Domino
and people sit their asses at home
we must not allow
this distraction to affect turnout
that is the most important thing
and yes am I a rabble-rouser of course
why the [ __ ] do you think you can come
here
the whole point
no one in the mainstream media is going
to do this
none of them are gonna sit here
and cathartically make sure that you
understand what is at stake
this is the most important election of
your democracy's lifetime
and as soon as it's over as soon as as
soon as it's counted certified
the next one will be
and they're distracting you with that
Jake Tapper
has the president of the United States
sitting in front of him
the president of the United States
sitting in front of Jake Tapper and the
dumb [ __ ] asked him not about
this election but the next one the next
one are you gonna are you a Democrats
say are you gonna Jake Capper you are a
dumb [ __ ]
Jake Tapper you are a dumb [ __ ]
you are derelict in your duty
we are less than 30 days from this
election and you're asking the president
of the United States
about the next one
how in the [ __ ] do you you people keep
your [ __ ] jobs
everyone gets crazy ah Tony uses curse
words
goes after the Main Street you goddamn
right I go after the mainstream media
when they're derelict in their Duty we
should
we should attack them they're not the
enemy but Jake Tapper that was a dumb
[ __ ] stupid question a stupid line of
questioning
to ask the president of the United
States when he is literally
fending off
Vladimir Putin
possibly
initiating a nuclear war
we're headed towards fascism in this
country
they're saying it out loud we're white
Christian nationalists we're Nazis and
we want Nazism here in America America
First Nazi party all the way they're
saying it out loud they're telling you
they're gonna steal elections they're
saying it
in front of [ __ ] microphones in front
of crazy q and on crowds
and you're asking a [ __ ] if he's
gonna run or not in 2024 you dumb son of
a [ __ ] it's distraction
I'm telling you it's distraction
so when you're out there and you're
talking and they say something about Joe
Biden running 2024 you tell your friend
you tell your family member your
colleague
your fellow parishioner whoever it is
that's saying that [ __ ] you say that's a
distraction that's a distraction
for you not to go vote for you to get
discouraged for you to keep your eye off
the prize we are less than four [ __ ]
weeks away
and there's not going to be any October
surprises for Democrats
and it's clear
because we did a damn better job of
picking candidates
a damn better job of picking candidates
Republicans know it we know it the media
knows it the [ __ ] candidates know it
[ __ ] don't even live in these
states
Dr Oz does not live in Pennsylvania
Herschel Walker lives in Texas
Marco Rubio and anywhere he could be
found
I didn't know the [ __ ] exists
anymore
like some hologram or some [ __ ] have you
seen him
I haven't seen him Ron DeSantis is
running around in white rubber [ __ ]
Cowboy cheerleader boots but not Marco
Rubio
where are they
and where are they from but it's all
distraction folks and you can't get
distracted
foreign
There's real life consequences at hand
we're going to find out more tomorrow
about real life consequences
real life consequences
and what it's like to put fascists in
control of your government
apparently the January 6 Select
Committee
during their hearing tomorrow which we
will cover
and our normal time we will do an hour
of commentary before
we will cover the hearings and then we
will do an hour of commentary or so
after it just depends on when they end
and how long
so don't forget to go follow that link
over on the Midas touch Network
but we will be here same time same place
for that hearing tomorrow but the news
is this morning that there's been
Millions
now millions of lines of communication
of the Secret Service hmm you know me
and my co-host Gabe Sanchez and speaking
of Gabe he's not going to be here today
Gabe is off today it's just me you just
got me you'll be back here tomorrow for
the hearing but she just got me today
maybe he'll pop in I'm not sure but it's
his day off
guy deserves a day off every now and
then
I can't take a day off
I'm not going to either
not any time in the near future
but here's the thing
me and Gabe talked about I don't know
it's last week week four sometime I
don't remember
we talked about how the Secret Service
you just don't get rid of electronic
communication records that's not a thing
I mean even if you deleted off one
device or this device or you delete it
here you delete it there I mean these
this
this record this electronic record of
data lives in a lot of different places
and apparently in the January 6th select
committee has gotten their hands on it
now
the most important part about that is
tomorrow they're going to reveal some of
these communications apparently during
this hearing so you're not going to want
to miss this [ __ ]
you're going to want to come here and
watch it trust me
apparently
the reporting is
is that the Secret Service
shows Communications that Donald Trump
absolutely knew what was happening
this [ __ ] lie where he's like hey no
idea I wasn't watching TV I was I was
throwing ketchup against the wall I had
no idea what was going on down there at
the Capitol I took a nap no he knew
exactly what was going on
so much so that the Secret Service down
at the [ __ ] Capital was telling the
Secret Service back in the White House
apparently do not need he cannot come
down here it's too dangerous
they were terrified that the president
United States even after they had the
little the little scuffle
in the SUV
and he threw the ketchup against the
wall even after that apparently the
Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa poopy pants
wanted to go down to the Capitol
enter the capital
and Crown himself dictator and King
now you're saying why is that relevant
to 2022 because folks that's not a thing
that exists
there is nothing in our constitution
there is no mechanism in our government
that makes it to where the the sinning
president of the United States of
America can walk into the capital why
the votes are being certified
and he can have his supporters violently
take over the chamber he can walk up
gavel in and Crown himself King that is
not a [ __ ] thing
that is Q Anon nonsense
not even close to anything that
resembles our constitution or our
democracy not even [ __ ] close
but it sounds like that's the plan
doesn't it sound like that was his
[ __ ] plan
if Mike Pence wouldn't do it by God he'd
go down there and do it himself
listen to me when I tell you this this
is all delusional
it's all [ __ ] wacky they're [ __ ]
weirdos they don't understand how it
works but they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care how your democracy Works
they don't give a [ __ ] because they're
done with democracy they want autocracy
and they're willing to use your
democracy
to absolutely [ __ ] bury it
destroy it and take it from you
this delusional idea that they're going
to win back the house and somehow
impeach bite and Harris at the same time
and then what they're going to do is
make Trump the speaker of the house and
then he's third in line so he'll be the
president and
folks they're desperate they're cornered
they're losing support
by the droves
they're hanging on by threads
with these candidates that have locked
themselves in with the Cheeto dust
mobster with the treasonous piece of
[ __ ] that he is there listen Ashley
Babbitt is a traitor
and if you're simping for her today on
Twitter another distraction you are one
two
simple
very simple
Herschel Walker is Trump
mastriano is Trump JD Vance is Trump
DeSantis Marco Rubio Greg Abbott Blake
Masters Kerry Lake bobert Marjorie
Taylor green uh every [ __ ] one of
them Ron Johnson
Eric Schmidt their Trump
so if you see Trump as the threat which
trumpism is definitely the threat here
because it is America fascism in a Maga
hat
these America First Nazis
if you see that as the threat then go
act like it engage like it do something
about it
that's how democracy Works democracy
isn't handed to you it isn't automatic
that's why that's why this [ __ ]
narrative that liberalism is weak is
really [ __ ] stupid it's really
[ __ ] dumb
that liberalism is is weak
no it you know what's weak you cultist
[ __ ]
is to blindly follow one person into the
abyss
because what we'll do this we'll just
wave a magic wand and make everyone else
believe what I believe
I don't care if you believe what I
believe or not I really don't give a
[ __ ] honestly you had the right the
liberty and the freedom to be a dumb
[ __ ] you have that right and
that Liberty in this country
Alls I ask is that you just say it out
loud so we know who the [ __ ] you are
and boy do we know who the dumb
[ __ ] are
boy is it obvious
so act on it
do what democracy do best
which is Crush fascism that's why
they're terrified of it
that's why they don't want us to vote
that's why they're hoping we don't turn
out because they know the enemy of
fascism is democracy that's why they
[ __ ] hate it because they're [ __ ]
fascist and they know they are that's
what they want
and they're willing to impose it on us
any with any means necessary
even delusional [ __ ] plans like
Donald Trump walking down to the Capitol
making secret service make a an alley
for him so he can go to the
to the chamber and gavel in and Crown
himself King
Tony that's a conspiracy theory really
you you think we're not far from hearing
that's the [ __ ] truth
you haven't been paying attention
[ __ ] been standing on stage
telling people they just need to make me
president again we just need to have
another election we just need to
activate another election and make me
king president they just need to do this
to make me president maybe I'll be
speaker and they'll impeach and then
I'll be it's delusional
there's no [ __ ] presidential election
between now and 2024 it doesn't exist in
our constitution it doesn't exist it's
not [ __ ] real the possibility of them
making Trump speaker and him becoming
president
is delusional
it's [ __ ] delusional but they don't
give a [ __ ]
any means that they were laying pipe
bombs they planted pipe bombs
on January 5th for January 6th
[ __ ] don't plant pipe bombs
because they're not serious
about taking over your [ __ ]
they don't bring guns and weapons
disguised as flagpoles to beat the hell
out of Capitol Police that anyone
willing to stand in their way
of their authoritarian figure
they're [ __ ] serious about it
and they don't care about Norms they
don't care about rules they don't give a
[ __ ] about your Constitution because
they think they're entitled to this
country
and they're going to use white supremacy
white Christian nationalism
they're going to use fear of violence
and crime they're going to use fear of
people of color
fear of transgender folks
our lgbtq brothers and sisters
fear of them their [ __ ] parents
books math critical race Theory
they're going to try to use all that to
convince you that you should stay at
home because you can't win well [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
let's show them what democracies can do
let's show them what antifa anti-fascism
can do
we Crush fascism around the world in the
30s and 40s with democracy we can do it
again
it's going to take a bit it's not just
this election that we're going to do it
it's going to take a bit more effort for
the next one
but we can do it we got this [ __ ]
it's difficult democracy is hard it's a
hard long slog
what's the alternative
to let them destroy it
the greatest Democratic experiment in
the history of humans right here in
America
it sparked Democratic experiments all
around the world when they saw what
Liberty does
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
anymore on it's fascism
and we
pro-democracy
coalitions should not relent
and we should not back down
we should not get complacent
we're only a few wait we're only a few
weeks away from sending the largest
message that these [ __ ] have
gotten so far
just weeks away from it don't quit now
I know you're not going to
but you must you must not let these
narratives take hold you must not let
these distractions take hold like Kanye
West who gives a rat's [ __ ] ass about
what Kanye West has to say about
anything anything [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] him
distraction
Kelsey gabbard she's not a Democrat [ __ ]
her she's a distraction
fetterman had a stroke so he has to read
but he's running around running he's
doing everything he needs to do to prove
the pennsylvanians that he's gonna be a
senator distraction
oh Mr President are you gonna run in 20
2084 distraction
it's time for us to take the narrative
and run with it [ __ ] them
it's our narrative it's our democracy We
the People we're the government anyways
to hell with them
turn the [ __ ] off and come listen to
some pro-democracy speech
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
you're the best audience in the world
and I'm lucky to have you
and you're lucky to be here in the chat
whether you're on Facebook YouTube
twitch Twitter
you're part of History I know it doesn't
feel like it in the moment
but you're part of History
you will look back and your children
your grandchildren
and after you're long gone they'll say
what did these people do what did they
do
how did they do it
and how do we get more of that
so set an example
not just not just for now for the future
show them show them how to crush fascism
they
our great leaders showed us in the 1930s
and 40s how to crush it
how to how to get rid of Nazi Germany
in fascist Italy
and Crush Japan
fascism all around the world we crushed
it they showed us
now we must act
like we know they showed us
like we know history like we know what's
happening
so don't get distracted
I on the prize and the prize is
democracy
I appreciate you joining me here today
we're gonna go we're gonna go an hour
and a half with the shitless Roundup
we're gonna round up the Tweet tweets I
have some videos that I want to show you
from yesterday
that we didn't just have time to show
and I'm gonna show you some videos of
what is distraction why it's distraction
so when someone's talking about it out
there you can [ __ ] you can wad it up
and throw it in the [ __ ] trash
got it
we do not look away here
sunlight is the best disinfectant
the other thing I try to do is
give you some cathartic release but also
show you how to handle this nonsense
when you're out there talking
how to handle the nonsense how to
absolutely tear up and Destroy any
argument even if it's coming from our
side
like oh well maybe there's a maybe
there's a good point that fetterman has
to re he can read he can read hell half
the [ __ ] mogulodites that are going
to vote for Oz I can't even [ __ ] read
they don't want to read hell they're
banning books they don't want to read
what the [ __ ]
there's your good starting point
of how fascism works
everybody
let me tell you something this this
phrase
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not Liberty is the reason why I'm
sitting here I said this many two years
ago in a tick tock
it is the reason why I'm sitting here
people grasp onto this phrase
and you guys love these shirts I had no
idea that you would like these shirts so
much but everyone loves this design so
much so that we made a hoodie
here's the hoodie it's in a couple
different colors we put it on the back
of the hoodie and then put Lady Liberty
on the front you can see there
so go to store not beat Tony
michaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com you can use
the promo code podcast to get 10 off
use the promo code podcast to get 10 off
your Liberty hoodie
this is the phrase of our show this is
the phrase of our time
and if we can get more and more people
to understand
what this phrase means
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
our democracy will be stronger on the
other side
of The Strife that we have right now and
I believe that what we're doing right
now the work we're doing right now is
making our democracy stronger
because as much garbage As Trump fed us
and keeps feeding us and lies and
[ __ ] and crookedness and crime
there's one thing that he gave us folks
there's one thing he gave us we all know
now how important it is to work for
democracy that it's not automatic
that you goddamn right authoritarians
can take over one of our parties in this
country and I can't wait for the day
when we actually have two parties again
it will be much easier to work through
and save our democracy when there's
threats inside our democracy right now
it's not time to relent we must lean in
we must not worry too much
about what the future may hold
we must make the future in our democracy
today
and it's important that we keep our eye
on today
so if you like the phrase like the
sentiment the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people it's not Liberty
wear it loudly and proudly we've got
hoodies t-shirts go to store.doney
michaels.com again you're the greatest
audience in the world I appreciate all
your support
means so much to me that you guys loved
that shirt that there that's the best
selling design that we have right now
and it means so much to me it really
does not just because it's something I
said and it's my phrase and it's in the
intro
but it means to me that you feel that
same phrase deep down inside of you
that there are pro-democracy people out
there
that there's we're still here baby and
we're not going anywhere so don't you go
anywhere we're gonna be back with a
shitless Roundup right after this break
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around through the break
everyone's talking about these hoodies
in the chat here they want a zip up
Hoodie not just a pullover hoodie but
your wish is my command I'll make you a
deal
since you love the design you'll love
the hoodie so much I'll see what I can
work on to get a zip up Hoodie up on the
store today
so here's what we'll do I'll see if I
can get that design up on the store uh
that listing for you to go get a zip up
hoodie
um and I will what I'll do is I'll post
it on YouTube and uh Twitter and maybe
all the maybe all the social medias the
uh instagrammies the books of face we'll
put it all over there that way you guys
have that so I'll try to get that
together this afternoon after the show
as I prepare for the January 6 select
hearing tomorrow I think this is going
to be our last one
I know they keep saying oh well uh maybe
there'll be another one maybe I don't I
don't think they're gonna have another
one folks
we're getting down to the wire here
um especially if we don't get out and
vote and pile these [ __ ] up
with the mountains of votes and the
Republicans take the house we're
definitely not going to have any more
hearings I wouldn't imagine and there's
come January there won't be any January
6th Select Committee
there'll be a committee that's
criminally investigating into Congress
all all the all Trump's enemies
who are trying to hold him accountable
that's literally what's going to happen
if we don't pile them underneath
mountains of votes
so it is vitally important that you do
that but I'll make a deal as I'm
preparing for the January 6 select
hearings I will I will investigate and
post trying to post I believe I believe
they have the in our merch store they
have the availability of doing zip UPS
I'm almost positive about this
um I just didn't know how popular the
zipper putties would be
but apparently
everyone would like one yes there is a
zip hoodie
there is a zip hoodie so I will I will
put together
I'll put together a zip hoodie for
everyone
and we'll make it the exact same as the
design on the hoodie here this one this
one right here
same design just zip up instead of
pullover deal
I'll make you that deal
when you have to come watch tomorrow the
January 6 select earring
and that's the deal I'll make with you
and you can watch it on the Midas touch
Network the link is already over there
or you can come watch at our regular
time here as well so don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel it's
very important
and boy have you guys been subscribing
again a lot of new subscribers here on
the Tony Michaels podcast but also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
POD at the Tony Michaels and at I am
Gabe Sanchez in case there's any change
of plans
you know these the the January 6 select
gearing committee they like to
throw wrenches in the last minute so
make sure to follow us there on Twitter
as well you can also follow us on
Facebook if you're on the Midas touch
Facebook page head over to my page we
broadcast there too at the Tony Michaels
and we're our page on Facebook like us
there
you don't want to miss a thing because I
post all my memes that I find over there
as well as on Instagram you can follow
me there too
you can also follow us on Twitch if you
like the twitch some people like the
chat and twitch better
there's a lot of people in the twitch
chat and they like it better it's a
little different over on Twitch
it's it's not a lot just a little some
people like it some people like the some
people see look
and this person says I love twitch
right here's all the twitchers here
they're in the chat look at them look at
him go let's go see
yeah they like the
if if you like twitch you're gonna like
twitch you're just gonna like it
so try it out if you haven't tried
twitch out you may maybe go over there
download the app it's free and I know
you don't want to get another app on
your phone
but you know try it out maybe you'll
like twitch over there because we're
going to broadcast the January 6 elect
hearing on Twitch as well it will be
there
it's going to be on the Midas touch
twitch Channel it'll be on our Channel
as well same time same place
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
now the hearing say this is the question
we always get the like Jesus Christ I
thought the hearing was at one Eastern
well it is at one Eastern
it is at one Eastern
the the problem is we want to do
commentary before so we do an hour's
worth of commentary tomorrow I believe
we get uh we got the likes of Texas Paul
uh Jessica Denton I believe is going to
join us Michael popock from legal app
I'm sure the my zealous Brothers will be
there Gabe's gonna be there
I know David Bender
is going to be there I think I think on
the after coverage
so after the hearing's over the Ascend
coverage as I would say in my neck of
the woods that's what I would say it's
the ass in coverage you know it's the
the back the back part
so the coverage after the hearing is
over we're going to have I believe we're
gonna have politics girl
um we may or may not have Michael Cohen
we always like to have Michael Cohen's
take on what's going on especially with
the Secret Service Trump
um but I I believe he's a little busy
this week
so I'm not I'm not sure we'll have him
but I I think we're gonna have Dr Rachel
bittickoffer what my favorite political
strategist I know David Bender Texas
Paul will be there uh the my zealous
Brothers will probably Gabe and I'm will
definitely be there
on the after coverage so don't forget to
to join us at noon Eastern for the
coverage leading up to the hearing we
will Air the hearing live the entirety
of the hearing
and then what we will do is we will do
commentary afterwards to give our
insight into what we just saw and what
we just witnessed
from the great Midas Mighty panel
so don't forget to join us tomorrow
to see politics girl Dr Rachel
bidikoffer Jessica Denson Michael popock
the my zealous Brothers me and Gabe
deliver you the last and final which I
think will be the final January 6th
select here now they may have some more
hearings but they're not going to be
like the hearings that we've had so far
um where they're where they're laying
out evidence that they've gathered it'll
probably be hearings on what what will
be the recommendations for legislation
going forward
um they may do hearings on that but it's
not going to be a
uh a big production like they've had in
the past or this last one that we're
we're going to see tomorrow because they
still have business to wrap up so
they'll still have public business to do
so they'll still have public hearings
but it's not going to be like the public
hearings that you know now it's it's
likely there is the the likelihood that
there could be some crazy evidence that
comes in you know at the last hour and
they decide that they definitely need
another hearing so then there's a
possibility that's why they're not
ruling it out
but it feels like to me this is just my
personal feeling since we've been
producing these hearings for Midas touch
that this will be the the final hearing
and what I what why I think why that's
so important right because a lot of
people might be disappointed I don't
know let's see let's see in the comments
I'm trying to pay attention to comments
today
um
um let's see
man what you know and maybe maybe people
want to make sure
that we have more hearings but here's
why it's so important if tomorrow really
is the last hearing
if the January 6 elect committee
their overall plan arching plan is that
this may be the last hearing that they
may have
then they're going to use it to make
sure to ring a bell
um there wasn't this hearing planned in
the original set of hearings hell there
was two hearings that weren't really
planned in the last set of hearings in
season one of treason Hunters
now we're in season two of treason
Hunters
but this select earring is likely to
ring a bell we are probably going to get
a lot of information
that is going to
Ripple throughout our country
it's probably not going to be
information that we really liked here to
be quite honest with you
um if if this reporting on the Secret
Service
is at all accurate it really feels like
to me
that there were actors inside our
government
that were capitulating
against their oath possibly
and what I mean by that is they it
didn't seem like they were overtly
acting against their oath
but it it just with this what the
[ __ ] Cheeto does mobster
the capitulation is high
it's high
and for whatever reason they don't think
that it's dangerous in the moment
and it's highly dangerous with these
fascists
these people who want to be
authoritarians
so this information that we will see
tomorrow is probably not information
that the overall General Public
that is not truth that they want to hear
and what I mean by that is they don't
want to really hear that the Secret
Service was capitulating
that this guy was going to overturn our
election that is probably not what they
want to hear or they were overtly
breaking their oath
because January 6 elect committee has
the evidence
now what that evidence says and tells
we'll find out tomorrow if they tell us
but I think it's going to be a dark day
in American history if we find out that
overtly or by capitulation at the Secret
Service
was trying to help another authoritarian
figure
subvert our democracy and break their
oath in that in that meantime
shot really it's a dark day
that's a dark day
but we must know the [ __ ] truth
we cannot look away at this stuff
folks
if this [ __ ] if this dip [ __ ]
if he was able to convince
the Secret Service in whatever shape or
form rather it's overtly or capitulation
to help him subvert our democracy
we have to stay vigilant
it is super important
you don't think when these Republicans
take over that they're not going to
operate
under that same design
that almost they see it as it almost
worked oh January 6th was great because
it almost worked that's what they love
about January 6. they hate that it
didn't work
they love that it almost worked that
they now have another plan laid out
and we must head them off
and the way we do that is to know the
[ __ ] truth
to know the [ __ ] truth
and we must not get distracted by
individuals like Jeremy here who
obsessed who are obsessed with sixth in
sexual immortality oh Jeremy oh my God
Jeremy Johnson on Facebook he's like
fake Gabe he's just worse
oh man
them them bathrooms and that genitalia
in your pants that's the problem you're
a dumb [ __ ] Jeremy whoosh
whoosh if you believe
that sex is our problem in this country
you're not paying attention oh look look
at those sexual deviants over there
raising gas prices making sure your
wages are down making sure you go broke
because of a medical bill look at those
sexual deviants over there
making sure that your kids aren't
educated at three instead of instead of
five
look at those sexual deviants over there
making sure that college isn't for you
are a stupid son of a [ __ ]
and I'm glad you're here every day
Jeremy
letting people know that you're a dumb
[ __ ] it's brilliant
it's brilliant like I said in the first
30 minutes you have the right in this
country
to be stupid
it's your Liberty to be a dumb
[ __ ]
boy are you exercising that right
in the Facebook chat
well let's do this we got I got some
video I want to show you everyone we're
gonna go to the Tweety tweets and trendy
Trends we must round up the [ __ ] list so
let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome back to the show Welcome to the
shitless Roundup where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends
talking about shitless Jeremy's still I
don't know where fake Gabe's at today
anybody is fake game out there maybe
Texas ball uh really did wad him up and
throw him in the trash yesterday I don't
know if you [ __ ]
I don't know if you caught yesterday's
show holy [ __ ] if you didn't catch
yesterday's show you need to go watch it
or you can just go to the YouTube
channel you go to the YouTube channel
and you can find the Texas Paul
conversation that we had yesterday and
boy did he come in [ __ ] hot I mean he
came in smoking
he was at the cousin Pond and it I mean
it was here on the show but he yeah he
certainly thought he was at the cousin
Bond he didn't he let loose yesterday as
soon as he got as soon as his mic was
hot he let loose
and fake Gabe thought he was gonna give
it to Old Texas Paul
Texas Paul must have run him off I don't
know maybe he's here in the chat but old
Jeremy here says smart people understand
the 2022 elections were stolen remember
when I just I just said it Jeremy I just
said it before the the [ __ ] music for
the shitlist Roundup I just said it you
absolutely have the liberty and the
right and the freedom to be a dumb
[ __ ]
and you certainly you certainly are
using your rights today in the chat
oh my god oh it's wonderful keep
chatting keep typing in your comments
and pump that algorithm get my voice out
to more people
maybe some people will hear it that are
like you and understand
who why sometimes exercising your rights
to stupidity is not the way to go
yeah
whoosh
whoosh
artsy is fake Gabe in the chat where is
he today oh man we ran him off well son
of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
I like having fake Gabe here no I'm
serious why not
again again how are you going to combat
this stuff how are you going to know
what arguments you're going to form if
you don't know what to form the
argument's against
laughs
ah someone said oh Tony you had to bring
a fake Gabe you had to bring him up a
date without fake Gage [ __ ] is an
awesome day listen I'm telling you I'm
telling you the only way you're gonna
know how to comment this stuff
the only way you know is to know what
their arguments are before they say them
that's the way to know it
that's why it's so easy for me to set
Jeremy or fig Gabe up on the tee and
absolutely knocked him out of the park I
know exactly what they're going to say
before they say it I watch this [ __ ]
I watch more [ __ ] than you see me do
here on the show I watch I watch some
crazy ass [ __ ] listen to some crazy
[ __ ] clips
read some crazy nonsense that these
people believe listen
for years for years and years and years
I listened to Rush Limbaugh and Sean
Hannity's show not because I liked it
not because I wanted to torture myself
but that is where they got their
arguments
like literally if you had if you had a
republican where you worked with right
if you had a republican where you work
with and they did not listen to Rush
Limbaugh or Sean Hannity
they were always about three days maybe
four behind what Russian Sean Hannity
were saying okay so listen to this this
is real [ __ ] I'm giving you the truth
here
this is why I would listen to their
[ __ ] show now I once Trump came along
and they [ __ ] sent for him I couldn't
I couldn't stomach anymore it was really
bad I had to go to Mark Levin even
Mark Levin at least was parroting what
Limbaugh and Hannity and Glenn Beck were
saying by the evening time he was doing
his syndicated show
and he was he was parroting
what they they were he was just
repeating what the [ __ ] mimicking
what they were saying
on his show but at the time Mark Levin
[ __ ] hated Trump he [ __ ] hated him
now he loves him you know because
fascism good
I mean they they always saw Trump as a
[ __ ] and that's why they didn't like
him the reason why they didn't like
Trump in the beginning is because they
didn't think he would make a good
fascist leader because he's a dummy
that's why they and they still don't
like him but they love fascism okay they
love it they [ __ ] love it
and he was better fascist dictator type
than they ever dreamed he would be
that's why they [ __ ] sent for him now
but I listened to Rush Limbaugh and Sean
Hannity for years for years I listened
to them and the reason why I would
listen to them is to know what dummies
like Jeremy and Gabe's arguments were
gonna be three or four days in advance
three or four [ __ ] days I knew what
they were gonna say to me
that's how it worked
before I mean this was this was when
social media was starting to take hold
but not like not like now not like where
you have all these Boomers on Facebook
and Twitter and Instagram Gathering and
Telegram and parlor and fraud social
Gathering up all this [ __ ] this
disinformation just just [ __ ]
nonsense
their Outlet at the time was talk radio
that was their Outlet at the time to get
all this disinformation out
and they would use it as their apparatus
to get this disinformation out that was
the point
that was the whole purpose that's why
that's why Rush Limbaugh was on at noon
is so that he could get their talking
points in the 90s because you got to
remember in the 90s there wasn't [ __ ]
social media there wasn't this Mass
internet media
like we have now it was a different time
the papers would print in the morning
and a lot of people read their paper in
the morning but most folks
that that voted Republican
they wouldn't raise their news in the
midwest till the evening
that's right they would in the Midwest
republican world and Trump land
they would read their news in the
evening because what they would do is
they go to the grocery store and get
their groceries or go to the gas station
and get their gas and they would grab a
local newspaper
and they they take the newspaper home
they wanted you know the garage sales
the the the the the local events and
everything inside there maybe the
funnies that had been tucked away in
there the local the local uh scores for
football games
stats
for their sports teams that they were
trying to keep track of all that was
tucked in this little local paper
they weren't reading New York Times in
the Washington Post
they weren't up in time
a lot of blue collar workers
they would consume their news and little
Snippets in the evening through the
local newspaper and the local news
and 30 minutes of national news whether
they were watching whatever one of the
three networks that they were watching
ABC NBC or CBS
with the right-wing talkers understood
and rushed more than any of them is that
if we can get our narrative if we can
get our lies out in front of the news
out in front of the truth
and we can get all these people to
believe the nonsense before the news
even comes on
right think about this
between noon Eastern three o'clock
Eastern which is which is really eleven
to two which is lunch time
in the Midwest
and it's lunchtime in the Rust Belt
if we can get all these people who could
vote Republican to believe the lies and
misinformation and nonsense about what's
going on before they read the news
before they watch the news
we will already create bias in their
mind
that was the [ __ ] purpose
that's the whole goal that was the
[ __ ] model
and then Murdoch and Roger Ailes came
along and said not only not only are we
gonna [ __ ] feed him up what
misinformation and what dumbass lies
arguments that we want them to have
before they hear the news we're going to
create a whole News Channel full of lies
and misinformation and [ __ ] and
dribble for these people to Feast on all
night long
and it worked marvelous it worked
fantastic in this country
to roll us towards straight up [ __ ]
fascism
the Wright did a great job at messaging
they did a great job at programming
average Americans into believing
outright [ __ ] lies
just absolute dribble when I would
listen to rushing them all and Sean
Hannity I would be doing the same thing
then that I'm doing right now I'm dead
serious it would be no different just
like I would pull a video up here and
yell and scream and [ __ ] get
cathartic
and absolutely tear it a piece by piece
by piece by piece by Bit by Bit by Bit I
would do it to the radio
and I did this for years
and the reason why the reason why I did
it is because I wanted to be three or
four days out in front of some idiot's
arguments
now the more the internet got popular
the less that window closed
here's what I mean
you go on the internet now you only have
hours to get out in front of an argument
maybe minutes
not days
not days
but minutes
and this queuing on stuff spreads
[ __ ] fast when these people have this
disease by God when it metastasized
inside their brain
boy baby does it take hold just like
Jeremy and fake Gabe they absolutely are
the Trump copy machine
they can't help they can't help but
devour misinformation and come here and
spew it in the chat
matter of fact they're directed to do
that
they're taught to do it
you must save America by going and
spreading misinformation in the chat
on some guy's show that gets you know 50
75 000 views a week
he does two hour show that's her goal
because Super PAC cabal that really is
dumb [ __ ] but they do it every [ __ ]
day
that's why I'm appreciating that they're
here
because they're hearing it
it's okay Jeremy it's okay fake Gabe
it's cool
I know if you stay here and you listen
to the truth long enough
long enough
there'll be a moment moment
where a kernel of truth will break its
way through your tiny little brain
and that little kernel of truth will
snap something
and if it doesn't it was worth the
[ __ ] shot it was worth a shot it was
worth a shot
but that's what we're up against folks
that's what we're literally up against
is they're methodical long-term goal to
take us into Fascism and
authoritarianism
by picking a Time on the radio
that's right
picking a Time on the radio in the 90s
was a strategy
to make us more right-wing to make us
more fascist
to marginalize more groups
just like we're seeing right now with
trumpism
what do you think trumpism came out of
nowhere do you think Jeremy invented all
the phrases that he's saying in the chat
ah [ __ ] you think he's inventing this
stuff
hell to the no
that's the answer he's not making this
[ __ ] up
he's not doing his own research he's
being fed this [ __ ] and he's coming here
and typing it in the chat same as fake
Gabe
I don't know if they're on email chains
if they're in Facebook groups what
they're following on Facebook or Twitter
but they are being fed a bunch of
garbage
and that's why you gotta stay ahead of
it
it's important to our democracy that you
the people who are pro-democracy know
exactly what the [ __ ] they're gonna say
and how to combat it in the moment
that's the problem that we have right
now with the media is they have no ideas
they still don't have any idea how to
come back
wise
they were flooded with lies for four
years
and they expect now now they expect
someone who's a decent human being
who's the president that is a low bar
that we have for President United States
you know that decent human being it's a
low [ __ ] bar but just because
he's a decent human being they're trying
to like oh surely Joe Biden's lying like
you guys got to get out of the Trump
Loop
you gotta quit the habit
just because the last [ __ ]
was a malignant narcissist
and couldn't help himself but lying
doesn't mean everyone else does it
now I'm not saying that all politicians
don't twist the truth hell that's
politics baby that's why Lindsey
Graham's so pissed off
but that's why I want to arm you with
the ability to absolutely Crush these
son of a [ __ ] before they get to
their argument before they finish their
sentence you know what they're gonna say
and they did it for years for years I
would know it was it was it was
hilarious because I had certain people
that I would argue with
and they didn't know it but I knew their
arguments four days before they knew I
knew their arguments and the reason why
is because they weren't watching Rush
and Sean Hannity and you say well Tony
well then how will they come up with
these arguments that's the point not
everyone would have to watch and listen
to that drivel for it to work its way
into their minds
that's the whole point
that's the whole point of lies and
misinformation
that's why they pile it on you that's
why Jeremy and Gabe can't stop [ __ ]
commenting and saying lies
they can't stop they won't stop
and it's because
that's the point is it leaks from one
group one unsuspecting group to the next
unsuspecting group to the next
unsuspecting group that's why you have
to spread a message of democracy
that's why we must not relent that's why
we must lean into it
because the more we talk about democracy
the more we look in a prism of a world
view of democracy and not well we could
be fascist what if we're not a democracy
that's why tyt the Young Turks sucks
that's why the Young Turks suck there
it's a bunch of dribble over there too
that's right Jeremy and fake Gabe I said
it those liberal Cuts over there they're
trash and the reason why is because they
do that thing
well maybe maybe we don't have democracy
maybe both sides are the same both sides
of all politicians the same there's not
one policy maker that's different than
the other [ __ ] if you don't know
that there's a difference between
Marjorie Taylor green
and someone like Sheridan Brown someone
like Adam Schiff someone like I don't
know Jeremy Ranch Jamie ranskin
serious [ __ ] policy makers people who
are serious about setting policy for us
they're bosses we are their [ __ ]
bosses
if you don't think there's a difference
you are a stupid [ __ ]
and to go around saying well there's no
difference between any politicians
they're all the same they're all liars
and we don't have a democracy really
it's not really a democracy
then you're doing the fascist bidding is
what you're doing
that's what you're doing you're
destroying democracy with your own
[ __ ] Thoughts with your own
forethought in your own words
and you're projecting it out in the
world for others to believe
so when you're doing it you're doing
damage to what you love most so stop
listening stop listening to the [ __ ]
and focus on what matters and know that
you have to combat it
you have to come at it
with a really sharp [ __ ] Edge
and destroy it Slice It Up dice it like
Tim Ryan did JD Vance that's a [ __ ]
Master Class into how to handle these
[ __ ]
Tim Ryan knew exactly knew exactly what
JD Vance would say knew exactly what JD
Vance has done
what his stance has been
and what that [ __ ] fraud says now and
he destroyed him destroyed him
and that's what we must do every single
day for our democracy it is our civic
duty not just to vote but to participate
to engage
and yes there's a lot of folks out there
that don't know much about Governor that
don't know much about Civics don't know
much about our democracy
but they do want to keep it
so you must engage with them make them
understand a little bit hear a little
bit there
they'll get there
because if you don't if you don't
people like Jeremy and Vick Gabe are
going to trust me they will they will
just like they're in the Commons here
every single day every single [ __ ]
day Jeremy makes me think he's a Russian
troll really honestly didn't he
he's talking about all kinds of weird
[ __ ] he talks about sexuality and how
Trump's the king and he's a god
ooh
Jeremy get a life
okay let's get to the Tweety tweets and
the trendy Trends here I got some
[ __ ]
some images I want to show you let's see
what's the first one
that we should go to
um you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of attacks like I said uh on on your
consent
I've been saying it for a long time uh
Aaron Reed has this horrifying hb6454
has been introduced in the state of
Michigan it defines getting gender
affirm affirming care for your trans
teen as child abuse in the first degree
it's purpose lifetime imprisonment for
parents of trans youth
did you hear what I just said
they are going to strip away
consent
from parents
whose children
are seeking gender affirming care
not not not
drugs not H6 changes Jeremy's going to
say I know what Jeremy's going to say
here because he's a bigot I know what
you're going to say Jeremy gender
affirming care
is a whole
medical and institutional guide
of care for someone who is questioning
their gender
it ranges from counseling
to other
medical attention
they're going to make it lifetime
imprisonment for the parents
are you are you listening to what I'm
saying
in other words
if a teenage child out there
has a question
about their identity about their gender
they can't seek any
any care
for that condition
the reason why is because their parents
will be imprisoned what do you think is
going to happen to the children
you think they're just gonna go on in
their merry way
hell to the no and it won't stop here
folks it's not gonna stop here
with gender affirming care it won't stop
there just like they didn't stop at row
they wanna they kept saying oh it's
about states rights states rights they
want a National Abortion ban
listen to them when they're telling you
who they are
gender affirming care even just the
simple Act of counseling
the simple Act of counseling will bring
a lifetime imprisonment sentence they're
taking away the consent
of your children away from you
that's what they want the [ __ ] in
Tennessee want to marry children
they're Predators I said this yesterday
they're [ __ ] predators
and this isn't about trans people folks
I I know I know they're using a
marginalized group
to institutionalize their fascism here
that is what they're doing
and it is it is gross that they use such
a marginalized group in the state of
Michigan to Institute policies where if
there is a level of care that they and
their religion doesn't agree with then
they get to take your consent away from
from you and imprison you for life
where does this end
where does this end
does this end if there's a [ __ ]
right-wing crazy nut job who just has to
have him some weapons of war and he just
must go into an elementary school and
Slaughter children
and then those parents are seeking
counseling for those children because
they were [ __ ] tortured because of
Republican policies
and they say as much you don't think
they'll take away your consent for that
type of counseling
you don't think when when a a teenager
who is questioning their sexuality which
almost all teenagers do
and is being bullied by right-wing
little [ __ ] [ __ ] jobs because their
parents are raising them to be [ __ ]
boxes
and they want to take their life and
they seek counseling
you don't think they're trying to take
your consent away from you
I'm telling you they didn't stop at Roe
and this this goes far beyond far beyond
bodily autonomy it goes far beyond
gender affirming care
they're using this as their way to take
your rights away from you
and they're using their [ __ ] religion
to do it
they're using their beliefs
and their freedom to oppress your rights
and trying to frame it up as Liberty
well [ __ ] that [ __ ] that ain't what it
is
and this is a view of it right here
they're going they're going to destroy
destroy a marginalized community's lives
be just even questioning just even
questioning your own gender
as a teenager
such a margin Alliance Community such a
small percentage of children in Michigan
that they are going to use as their
crutch to take away your consent of your
children
and it is not going to stop at gender
affirming care
it won't folks
it won't and if you don't do the thing
that you need to do and protect those
parents and those children
who who need gender affirming care
rather it be counseling or whatever it
may be
to keep the mental state of their child
in a level that they don't commit
suicide
if you don't protect them
then they're gonna come after you next
look at what they're doing with Roe it
was all about states rights up until
they overturned it and then it was not
about states rights anymore it's about a
National Abortion man we're going to ban
all abortion and all states [ __ ] you you
do not get the right to your body
because you're a woman
and we are going to tell you what to do
when to do and where to force birth let
me tell you something if they get what
they want if they get their fascist
state
you're going to see pro-life
[ __ ] like Jeremy
calling for forced abortions
I'm dead serious
don't think it won't happen
what do you think means meets the end no
the ends meets the means
they definitely 100 percent
are going to use these things to oppress
you
so if you don't stand up for your lgbtq
brothers and sisters and their [ __ ]
Liberty and their [ __ ] rights they
know that you won't stand up for your
own
little by little bit by bit they'll rip
it away from you just like they're
ripping away from [ __ ] trans people
for crying out loud
one of the most marginalized communities
in our entire nation and we should
protect their Liberty
we should protect their freedom
because again if they can do it to you
and they can do it to these parents
and these children
they're gonna come after you
it's right here
they're trying it hb6 6454
they want to take away your consent
for your children and they're doing it
by marginalizing I'm already
marginalized community
so thank you Aaron for bringing that to
light I'm telling you this is the [ __ ]
that you got to say to these
[ __ ]
you have to say this stuff you have to
get out in front of this uh caroling has
the uh
the reporting on the Secret Service for
the hearing tomorrow she says new
January 6 hearing will highlight new
Secret Service surveillance video and
records showing Trump new about the
violence at January 6.
and he sought to stoke it
so we're gonna see the Secret Service
records that confirms what we know
again this isn't [ __ ] it's not news
that Trump wanted to overthrow our
election Jesus Christ that [ __ ] [ __ ]
box is staying saying it on stage he
wants to overthrow it all still
he still wants to overthrow it hell
Jeremy Jeremy the Trump copy machine is
saying it here in the [ __ ] chat oh my
god oh Trump King Trump the Jesus so I
love him
foreign
he's bigot look at him boys and girls
are different not the same this is an
accurate statement
he didn't even know what the hell he's
talking about has no clue
no clue that that he doesn't know yeah
boys and girls are different not the
same Jeremy they're different
and boys and girls those are identities
that you identify as
huh that's what a girl is that's what a
boy is
you [ __ ] idiot
did you know Jeremy you probably know a
trans person and you don't even know it
you don't even know it
okay and because that's how ridiculous
the boy girl argument what is a woman
what is a woman it is kind of Rich that
the right wing are running around asking
what a woman is trying to figure out
what a woman is speaking speaking a [ __ ]
box right Wingers
now Bex points this out
and he has to remember back
it was it was during the election
they were trying to stoke fear
in the hearts of people like Jeremy
trying to convince him the BLM and Aunt
tiefer going to take over the country
and they're gonna take your rats away
from you and they're gonna put you in
camps or whatever the [ __ ] I don't know
whatever the [ __ ] they were trying to
whatever they were trying to project
because it's all projection
but you remember this famous picture
that went around the internet where
someone spray painted Biden 2020 BLM
antifa on a garage door and they burnt
this guy's camper
you remember this
I know if you remember this or not
Jeremy it's probably your [ __ ]
neighbor okay
this is all the Stoke fear
in the hearts of people like Jeremy now
they don't they don't see this and
realize
and know this is fake immediately
this is fake immediately
immediately no this is fake
and the reason why you know it's fake is
just by the words that are written here
this is not what someone with antifa
would write
on the [ __ ] garage door of someone
they burnt down their camper
that's not what they would do and of
course Laura I'm a Nazi Ingraham and Ben
Lum little boy Lumber Shapiro here are
on Fox News talking about how Trump
supporters reportedly Target by arsonist
oh those antibi arsonists now this did
not age well as Beck's ones out here
this tweet did not age well I'm going to
show you why here
because Wu Tang for children posted a
four-part story this morning
it's a saga really
oh
here's what uh Wu-Tang for children says
I like to start the day with a four-part
story okay here's the here's the picture
again
and you can see the fire in the
background now this camper burning to
the ground
okay are you ready for this
um
Miss Hughes here says can't wait to see
this revealed as a white people [ __ ]
up their own property because they want
attention for the 9 000th time hmm that
was 9 23 2020. you got it that was 9 23
the picture was 9 23.
2020
this is over two years ago
oh look at your NBC nine hours ago
Minnesota Trump supporter who falsely
accused left-wing vandals of what
what wait a second wait a second this is
getting hairy here
Seth reports here just into Department
of Justice announces a Brooklyn Center
man
has pled guilty to wire fraud after
staging an arson laughs
Dennis Muller said the vandals spray
painted Biden 2020 BLM and antifa symbol
on his garage door and then burnt his
Camp camper because he flew a trump flag
this was yesterday
this was yesterday
okay you got it are you following me
Jeremy are you following me how you're
being dupe Demi
got it
you are an upset of a [ __ ]
this is how they fought for this stuff
yeah well hey hang on a second
they can't see it here they're gonna
accuse me of not showing it look there
look at there
10 11 22.
this guy is pled guilty to wire fraud
after staging an arson he stayed he
burnt his own camper to the ground now
the reason why they're probably getting
him on wire fraud is because he probably
collected insurance money
and there was a there was a bank
transfer of money and it's probably why
they're allowing him to to to get a
charge of wire fraud because not only
did he fake this arson but he probably
got insurance money over it too because
he had to do the thing that you have to
do if you're lying about an arson is you
have to seek the insurance for the
[ __ ] for the arson
for having your property destroyed and
people have insurance for that kind of
[ __ ]
and he probably he probably had to seek
out insurance because he lied about it
being an arson now if he to just burn it
to the ground and post it on social
media and
didn't really seek out any monetary
value or commit fraud on insurance forms
then he probably would have been in the
clear
but
he seems like a dumb son of a [ __ ] so
he did what dumb son of a [ __ ] do
which is commit federal crimes federal
crimes
oh boy
what an idiot
is it surprising though speaking of
idiots
here's an idiot here you know my God
continuing to be an idiot always been an
idiot always will be an idiot
let's listen to what he has to say
about how politics work and he also
needs to tell the story about the double
standard here this October surprise
against Herschel you think that's an
accident they waited this long to drop
it right before the election so here's
what you can do to help Herschel Walker
and it's not an accident Lindsay it you
are certainly 100 right
this October surprise is not an accident
at all that's what makes it an October
surprise that's what makes it an
election that's why we are going to win
these [ __ ] because Democrats
are not holding back anymore
they're going to fight for their
democracy any way in any way possible
that they must because they know the
stakes
they know what they're going to try to
do with your rights just like they are
in Michigan trying to take parents
consent away from their children
they won't stop there
and the [ __ ] is [ __ ] getting weirder
and weirder folks these people are
falling deeper and deeper into fascism
Just Like Old Jeremy in the chat here
Jewish gender resistor has this video
that he posted off of tick tock
and he says Maga quotes how dare you
kneel for the flag it represents freedom
and it must be respected
he's he's quoting like you know that's
how they feel because we all know that's
that's what they say
they know it's all [ __ ] because also
they say this we're gonna use this Trump
flag instead of American flag for the
national anthem it's totally normal
thing to do and super respectful yeah
okay
talk about [ __ ] disrespecting the
troops this literally literally watch
this video they are singing national
anthem what appears to be a demolition
derby or some kind of race I think it's
a demo derby though I've been to a few
of them in my life I am from the Midwest
but I'm not sure exactly but that's what
it appears to be or a dirt track race
one of the dirt track race or it's a
it's a [ __ ] demolition derby
but you see over the head of the guy
here you see a flag here then you're
gonna sing the national anthem watch
what's on that flag
[Music]
foreign
really honestly I don't need to hear him
we just need to see it uh because
they're singing the national anthem
uh there it is there it is you see that
it's Trump 2024.
huh how patriotic of them
how have they abandoned the American
flag they're so patriotic
it's a cult Jeremy you're part of a cult
it's a [ __ ] cult man
whoosh I mean here you play it I mean I
can play the [ __ ] music
but literally the flag says Trump 2024
I'll be back it's even the flag is Trump
speaking you are such a [ __ ] cult
that you can't even form a message on
your own on the flag where you're
worshiping your cult leader you have to
have it as if he's talking to you on the
flag
you people really are brain damaged
you honestly I hope I hope Democrats get
the house in the Senate so we can seek
mental health coverage for every
American including Jeremy and people
like Jeremy and people holding this flag
and singing the National Anthem to this
[ __ ] Trump flag they need mental
health health care now fast
it's a cult Jeremy it's a [ __ ] cult
whoosh okay let's uh
let's find something else but folks
that's what I'm telling you man I'm
telling you I'm telling you
I'm telling you the derangement is real
it's [ __ ] real
and these deranged ideas that you keep
hearing you're like Ah that's not gonna
happen it can't happen yeah it it's not
a thing that exists but it is the thing
they are going to try to do it is a
thing that they are going to try to do
and tomorrow we are going to find out in
this hearing what he tried to do by the
communication from the people who were
trying to [ __ ] protect him
we're gonna find out what his what the
[ __ ] story is now we know we know he
was trying to subvert our vote we know
he was trying to be a dictator we know
he wants to be an authoritarian these
are all things we know
we just don't have the the pure facts in
front of us
to lay it all out and they're going to
do that tomorrow apparently with these
Secret Service Communications about how
bad he wanted to go up to the Capitol
and Crown himself King
it's a cult Jeremy it's a cult
oh buddy woo baby okay here's another um
listen if you're not paying attention to
how desperate these [ __ ] are here is
Mike Lee
the sitting Republican in Utah I talked
about this yesterday but I didn't show
the clip and I think it's very important
that we show this
do you ever get the sense that Tucker
Carlson absolutely does not have a
thought in his brain by his resting dumb
face look at his resting dumb face holy
[ __ ]
it's pathetic anyways
Mike Lee is a sitting Republican senator
from Utah
the other sitting senator who is not in
a re-election fight is Mitt Romney now
the person running against Mike Lee is
Evan McMullen Evan McMullen is a former
Republican
he's running against Mike Lee and he's
he's creeping up in this race
these numbers are getting Tighter and
it's obvious that Mike Lee has gotten
internal polling that shows
that if he does not have Mitt Romney's
support he may lose that's that's why he
is going I'm telling you that is why
he's going to Fox News right now in this
moment begging the Fox News supporters
to pressure Romney into supporting him
that's what he's doing here he's going
to the shark army that is white
privilege tonight and getting people
like Jeremy to go comment on social
media everywhere Mitt Romney's an
[ __ ] if he doesn't support rightly
he's a traitor if he doesn't support
Mike Lee they're trying to activate the
shirt Army on Mitt Romney
so that Mitt Romney will throw his
support behind
Mike Lee the Republican now Mitt Romney
has not thrown his support
Behind These candidates because what
Mitt Romney says which he's a coward
because he's a [ __ ] weak coward
that's right I said it Mitt Romney is a
weak [ __ ] coward
he won't throw his support against Mike
Lee that's what he should be doing
Mike Lee was part of the Insurrection
Jesus Christ they were calling Mike Lee
They accidentally [ __ ] called Mike
Lee oh it's an accident okay yeah right
whatever
Mitt Romney is a coward by not going
against Mike Lee and crushing this
trumpism [ __ ] when he has a chance
stopping on it
and squashing it like a cockroach that
it is but my glee here is on Tucker
Carlson's White Privilege tonight and he
is begging begging the shark army
to go pressure Mitt Romney to back him
because I'm telling you the reason why
he's doing it is because internal
polling inside Mike Lee's campaign is
showing that if Mitt Romney does not
throw his weight behind Mike Lee he
might just lose listen
please get on board help me win
re-election help us do that you can get
your entire family to donate to me
please get on board help me well that
way there he's begging for for in that
but and um
that is that is his message to Mitt
Romney please get on board please help
me and oh yeah by the way if you're
listening go give me money please give
me money and Mitt Romney needs to back
me hey Jeremy how does it feel
how does it feel
for one of your trumped-up [ __ ]
candidates
your your best hope in Utah to win to
have a Republican Senate
to be out trying to hunt for Mitt
Romney's support because it's showing
that in Utah he won't win if he doesn't
get a sport how does that make you feel
buddy
as a she you want to see how to draw
wedges folks that's how you draw a wedge
because they [ __ ] oh Jeremy hates him
some [ __ ] Mitt Romney for sure 100
no question Jeremy hates him some Mitt
Romney I can already tell that I don't
even need to guess
I know I know yep see a bad guy say bad
guy bad guy that Mitt Romney he voted to
impeach he voted to impeach my Jesus
Romney not a good guy okay
you sound more and more Russian
like you are you is it late there where
you're at
Jeremy is it late I don't know seems
like I don't know it just seems that way
Romney not a good guy he's a bad guy he
went against my Jesus he voted to
impeach my king my Messiah
my cult leader
Romney is a piece of [ __ ] he's a coward
Romney is a [ __ ] coward now he's the
only Republican senator
that will be part of history that showed
that he wasn't that much of a coward
I mean
amongst another bunch of cowards he
doesn't look so cowardly
but here in this race he's a coward just
like cowardly Mitt Romney is supposed to
be
but Mike Lee is begging for his his
support for him to get behind him and
the reason why is because the polling is
showing
uh more projection speaking of
projection
let's check in on Pennsylvania's
Mussolini Doug mastriano
this [ __ ] guy
whoosh this guy he's an insurrectionist
by the way he's an election denier
he's basically a Russian bot at this
point he loves Putin he thinks Putin's
strong I think I think mastriano would
like Putin to be president more than he
would like Trump
he's the DeSantis of the north as he
likes to call him so he's definitely a
fascist
but here him and Charlie Kirk Charlie
Kirk two white dudes who have probably
never done anything in their lives to
figure out
anything not a [ __ ] single thing
about how abortion and abortion care
affects women
are surmising about the Dobbs effect now
if you're not aware of what the Dobbs
effect is here's what the Dobbs effect
is and here's why they're terrified of
it and here's why they're doing content
on it folks
the Dobbs effect
is the effect that is sweeping Across
the Nation
where women
and and allies of women like fathers
Brothers
cousins friends men who are like no
you're not going to take their [ __ ]
rights away what are you crazy
are terrified that they overstepped and
miscalculated here with overturning row
that's the Dobbs effect it's the same
effect that they they watched in Kansas
as Kansas said no to the referendum that
you're going to take away our [ __ ]
bodily autonomy Kansas Red Kansas said
no [ __ ]
and they're terrified of this this is
how they were going to lose they know it
they know if they lose
in this midterm it is because they
pissed us right the [ __ ] off and they
exposed who they are and they want to
take away our rights
and they will stop at nothing to do it
that's the Dobbs effect they are hoping
that the Dobbs effect dies I am betting
that it won't
I don't I don't know if you've ever
um
Matt
any woman they're really [ __ ] smart
women are way smarter than men way
[ __ ] smarter
way [ __ ] smarter
way smarter I mean women women honestly
could probably figure out a way to have
a world with no men like they can figure
it out some way somehow there might be a
world in the future
that's only women because they figure
out a way men could never [ __ ] figure
out a way the reason why because men
could never men could never carry
another human being for nine months
they're just too big of [ __ ] to do
that kind of [ __ ]
just couldn't do and they definitely
would not they would definitely not be
able to [ __ ] put up with someone
telling them they have to be forced to
birth something men could never do it
men could never be the only sex in the
only species women could be they'd
figure out a way
oh hell yeah they're that smart men are
stupid men are [ __ ] that's why we
rape and pillage and use violence to
take power
we have to resort to physical violence
rape murder genocide
because we're dumb
we're [ __ ] dumb
it's the caveman effect
women are much smarter that's why it is
it is high time not just this country
but this world that women finally get
the reins on it men have [ __ ] it up
long enough
we have [ __ ] it up long enough and I
know it's it's shitty that we have to
rely
on women to clean up our mess but by God
it it needs to be done
we have to get our [ __ ] under control
here
and the smarter of the two Sexes is the
one to do it
but Doug mastriano and Charlie Kirk just
do not understand they do not [ __ ]
understand that they not know [ __ ] not a
God damn [ __ ] thing
and nor do they want to know
a goddamn thing
about women Jesus Christ
the likes of Charlie Kirk and Doug
masturano
are the same [ __ ] Ben Shapiro
and Matt Walsh running around the
country literally asking the question
what is a woman
what the woman what do if you don't know
what a woman is by now Ben Shapiro Matt
Walsh Charlie Kirk and Doug mastriano
you do not need to be in charge of
anything
they are literally running around the
country and with a woman with the woman
I've never met one I've never had one
like me I really don't interested into
knowing what one is I just want you to
tell me what one is
really stupid [ __ ]
but here in this little clip Charlie
Kirk and dead mastriano
are surmising
that women are not going to be so pissed
that the the Dobbs effect is gonna fade
away ah it's just gonna fade off in the
distance women are going to forget about
this
and have these guys ever been in a
relationship in their life Jesus Christ
let's listen I wonder if this narrative
from the left you know since the Dobbs
case of how this is going to motivate
the left and all that is to get out the
vote I don't I didn't see that
I I agree and look I I think that you
know in some communities being pro-life
is a winner and someone's it could be
you know not so popular in Pennsylvania
but it's also it's getting lower and
lower on the priority and the energy I
think the Dobbs effect is fading
okay
Charlie Kirk you little cuck and
mastriano you [ __ ] bigger cuck listen
to me when I tell you this
the Dobbs effect
has a lot to do with bodily autonomy and
abortion but it has more to do with you
[ __ ] idiots wanting to strip away
rights and freedoms that are afforded to
Americans
I don't know if you guys lived through
the pandemic but when you try to tell
Americans what the [ __ ] to do even if
it's to to band together to fend off the
enemy of a virus they still do not
respond very well
when they're forced to do something
quote unquote forced
because safety ah you forced me to get a
vaccine which it was a choice it was
your Liberty not to get it oh you forced
me to wear a mask no you could have
stayed your ass at home it was your
choice but you ain't you you wanted to
go into the Walmart put the mask on
you're the one who wanted to go in there
they don't understand choices in Liberty
and freedom but that's a whole nother
[ __ ] episode here
but Charlie Kirk and Doug mastriano
they are miscalculating again they
really believe
that you the voters women
Brothers
sisters Sons
husbands
dads
out there
are going to stand back
and let these [ __ ] idiots Gaslight an
entire nation about abortion and taking
away people's rights
and knowing it's not about states rights
because now they want a national
abortionment and think they're going to
stop there
I'm not sure about you
but there's not too many of what Matt
Walsh would question was the woman
Matt Walsh a woman is a person who is
going to rise against your fascism
a woman is going to be smart enough to
know when you don't want to stop at her
[ __ ] rights to the privacy in her
doctor's office the rights to her bodily
autonomy she's smart enough to know that
that's what a [ __ ] woman is
also what a woman is is someone's wife
someone's sister someone's daughter
someone's cousin someone's friend
someone's colleague
and they don't want her rights to be
taken away either
that's what a woman is
and Charlie Kirk here and Doug mastriano
Matt Wallace Ben Shapiro and Donald
Trump and the rest of these [ __ ]
trumped up moglodytes this America First
Nazi party is about to really find out
the answer to the question
what is a woman but more importantly
what a woman is capable of you dumb
[ __ ]
need to get a life
you need to get a life and an actual
talking point that works
not just projection they're really
trying to project this out into the
world right and so they're trying to do
is Project this idea
that women
aren't going to come against us how
could they do that
how could they do that these women
aren't going to Camp against this
hmm it really is weird stuff some more
weird stuff
is this here and I told you yesterday
Tom Cotton you see him here on the
screen speaking of abortions and
murderers you pro-lifers you force
birthers out there who think abortion is
no exception and every abortion is
murder that's how Tom Cotton feels he
said as much every single abortion
service that there is
with that with no exception is murder
here he is smiling gazing upon
his token black dude
the guy who simps
seps for white people
keep their foot on the backs of
people of color their knee
and she smiles and gazes upon him
even though by Tom Cotton standard
Herschel Walker
is an accomplice of murder
now frankly I wish Herschel Walker and I
hope Herschel Walker paid for much more
than just one abortion
whoosh last thing we need running around
to be quite honest with you
is more of this nonsense
but by Tom Cotton's standard here
Herschel Walker is a murderer
look as he gazes upon him because folks
it's not about abortion it's not
not Tom Cotton look at him look at him
here look at it look at the smile on his
[ __ ] face
he's never been so happy since he
entered into one of those special kind
of clubs you know what I'm talking about
Jeremy you know what I'm talking about
Jeremy one of those kind of clubs guys
go to you know what I'm talking about
you don't want to talk about you don't
want to say anything about
Tom Cotton here is gazing upon Herschel
Walker
as if he's in love with him
and Tom Cotton knows has probably seen
the receipts
that are what he considers murder and
here's the point folks Tom Cotton does
not believe abortion's murder
he doesn't believe that [ __ ]
he doesn't believe that [ __ ] for one
moment
he only says that [ __ ]
to get the cult riled up to get the cult
to support him and people like him
white folk and black folk who only think
white folks should be in power like
Herschel Walker
that's his goal he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about abortion if Tom Cotton actually
had any kind of principle or any kind of
thought that abortion the most important
subject ever saved the children all
their murdering babies if he really
thought that he would not be standing on
stage gazing at a murderer
now I don't believe that Herschel Walker
is a murderer I mean
not because of portion the guy the guy's
a psychopath
he's held guns to his wife's ex-wife
said his girlfriend's head his head
other people's heads he's pulled weapons
on people so I don't know I mean it's
possible I'm not saying that has
happened but hypothetically you could
see how it could happen
but when we're talking about the
abortion that he paid for
Tom Cotton by all standards would
believe that ursha Walker is at least
and a bare minimum an accomplice to
murder because he paid for it and send
again well card maybe the get well card
is where
Tom gotten draws the line he's like you
know it's murder but he sent a [ __ ]
gas station get well card
so who am I to judge
[Laughter]
the story of the Mori here folks
is that Tom Cotton does not believe that
abortion is murder
it's all [ __ ]
he's trying to manipulate the cult
Jeremy you're part of the cult Jeremy
you're part of the cult I ain't looking
at Jeremy's comments here but I know
he's in here simping for Herschel Walker
and Tom gotten
he's just trying to convince the cult of
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] now listen
listen as he gazes upon him
what His Brilliant His Brilliant
hopefully future colleague hopefully not
says into a microphone the murderer by
the way
they'll do whatever it takes will say
whatever they have to say because they
want this seat right here
but I don't think they know that they
woke up a bear
hey I'm not just a dog now I'm a bear
foreign
now
here's the reason why you have to take
this seriously
because this is their method
in the race under Warnock and Herschel
Walker is that they believe they can
implore
the grab them by the [ __ ] strategy
which is just to ignore all principle
and all fact
and just continue on like Herschel
Walker never never did that
I mean Jesus Christ in fact I can show
you a video here
they're literally saying oh my God just
ignore just ignore it just ignore the
fact
hell just act like it's untruth if you
have to and even if it's true even if
it's true who gives a rat's ass let me
see if I can find it here it's some kind
of [ __ ] right-wing
you know off that key old podcast that I
saw
um oh here's here's an e here's a good
clip
here's the same [ __ ] weird meeting
somewhere else oh and I'm here's the
same meaning of the murderer
and the guy who says he's he's against
the murder he's against murder
and Herschel Walker's describing how he
wants to get people pregnant multiple
people pray I'm not [ __ ] you
he uses a story that he's been telling
on stage about how a bull in a in a
cattle pasture has gotten three
cows heifers pregnant listen as they've
been saying something is better
somewhere else and I'm here to tell you
it's not so I've been telling this
little story about this bull out in the
field with six cows the bull out in the
field with six cows
you got it there's one bull
six cows listen to what he says and
three of them are pregnant
so you know he got something going on
three of them are pregnant the other
three the bull paid for the abortion see
those cows didn't want to have that
Bull's calf so the bull apparently had
to pay
uh 700 bucks a piece
for this smortion uh the other ones
Jesus are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
there are they are they are they punking
us
are they trying to punk us
I'm telling you if you're not you're not
seeing the writing on the wall you need
to get out and right now if you can get
an early ballot and vote now
don't wait on this do not wait let me
see if I can find this clip that I'm
looking for where um they're simping for
him but saying no ignore ignore all
facts ignore all feelings
do not do not pay attention to the truth
and even if you believe the truth which
is the truth and the whole truth because
there's receipts and evidence
you still must vote for what you believe
is a murderer and the reason why is
because we have to take power it is the
only way that we have to take away
rights from women is to make sure that
even the most scummiest of scum that you
believe are scum are in power so that we
can strip the rights away from the
people we like less because we don't
actually believe that abortion's murder
that's not what we actually believe we
just use it as a political duel
to scare people and to get them to
activate to go vote
against Socialism or some [ __ ] I don't
know I'm not finding it but that's the
gist of it that's the gist of it
and when you when you boil down what
their argument is
and it's a woman giving this argument
now I'm not talking about Dana Loesch
this is a different totally different
um podcast
but they're saying it everywhere they're
simping everywhere for Herschel Walker
and there's a reason for it
they're they're begging conservative
Christians not
to relent just even if it's true even if
the abortion allegations are true
hold your nose and go vote for him
because we we have to make sure that
Herschel Walker takes away the rights of
everyone but his girlfriends to have
abortions that's what we must do
because that's what they really mean
when they're supporting Herschel Walker
when they go vote for Herschel Walker
folks and this is how you should [ __ ]
frame it up for him if you vote for
Herschel Walker you are voting
for only people like you to have
abortions that's what you're voting for
answer the ruining they they want to
have the right they just don't want you
to have the right
sounds working I'm not finding this clip
I should have retweeted it I don't know
I should have retweeted
um one other thing I want to show you
that's going to be thrown in your
[ __ ] face for days and days and days
here is Ashley Babbitt's mom
she's trending again she's training it's
really funny that Ashley bab is trending
and the reason why is because we found
out that Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham
told officer Fanon that
officer Fanon should have just shot the
Trump supporters the insurrectionists in
the head as they stormed the camera you
should just shot him just shot him they
did shoot one of them
they did
that's what they did Lindsay
and he got people like this dumb
[ __ ] on a stupid on a program
wrongly named the absolute truth and his
projection
I'm not [ __ ] this is on Lindell TV
and the show is called the absolute
Church oh my God
ah you can't you just can't make this
[ __ ] up
whoosh
God damn
it would be like calling my show The
Quiet guy right the quiet guy podcast
the quiet guy podcast with Tony Michaels
calling this show the absolute truth
oh [ __ ] me Okay let's listen to what
Ashley Babbage delusional mom has to say
you know January 6th if you talk to
people that were actually there they
talk about what an inspiring uplifting
patriotic day that was you know singing
patriotic songs and and enjoying the
company of patriotic people Ashley
included you know I I hold comfort in
the fact that I've seen her walking down
the inaugural path and I see that as one
of it was a happy moment in her life you
know it was a happy moment in her life
to go get killed in the name of delusion
in the name of a lie
Donald Trump got Ashley Babbitt killed
he got her killed because he convinced
her
that she could go overthrow the
government for him
Donald Trump killed Ashley Babbitt now
here's the thing Ashley Babbitt is a
[ __ ] traitor
no matter the delusion no matter why
are how [ __ ] sinister
the delusion may be she's a traitor
and if you're simping for her
you're a traitor too
because Ashley Babbitt met her moment
and it was the [ __ ] around and find out
moment
I haven't played this video yet but
we're about to wind up the show here so
let's play this [ __ ] around find out
explanation let's play this all right
today we're going to talk about how we
can find out and how much we can find
out and what it takes to get there so
first we have to decide how much do we
want to find out so let's say in this
case I want to find out
at a level of seven okay so I find that
level on my graph and I come
horizontally to my gradient line where
it intersects with my gradient line I'm
going to come straight down to where it
intersects with my [ __ ] around line that
there is going to tell me how much I
have to [ __ ] around to find out what I
need to find out see as you can see
the more you [ __ ] around
the more you're going to find out
and also if you stayed on here and you
never [ __ ] around
you'll never find out so I hope this
lesson is helpful thank you
Jeremy I can play it again for you if
you need to but ain't you know it's
pretty simple there the more you [ __ ]
around
the more you find out oh my God I can't
stop watching that video every time I
see it every time I see it posted I must
watch it it is a thing that I have to do
folks I appreciate you joining us today
for two full hours me uh me alone only
my boys today on the Tony Michaels
podcast thanks for joining us here same
time same place every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the books
of face
if you're on the mightiest touch
Facebook page go follow me on Facebook
at Tony Michaels at the Tony Michaels
that's what it is at the Tony Michaels
on Facebook follow us there I post memes
over there I I actually I I the only
thing I can do on Midas Touch Facebook
is just broadcast this
a lot of people think like I have
control I I can't I I can just broadcast
there that's it I just have the ability
to post the video there here's the good
news tomorrow on Midas Touch Facebook
page we'll have the hearing so all of
you out there on Facebook right now
we're going to have the hearing on
Facebook we will broadcast I have the
ability to broadcast there so we will
broadcast that simulcast of the coverage
of the January 6 hearing it starts at
noon same time we start every single day
and if you're on YouTube you it will
broadcast here on our channel so follow
our Channel at Tony Michaels podcast
it'll subscribe here it will also
broadcast to the Midas touch Facebook
page or the mind is Touch YouTube
channel so go follow the minus touch
network if you want to follow there the
link is already over there on Midas
Touch
so wherever you want to watch it
Facebook YouTube
twitch if you're on Twitch it'll
broadcast to Twitch you can watch it
there as well it won't broadcast to
Twitter we don't broadcast the hearings
to Twitter
I'm sorry the Tweety tweets you'll have
to find the YouTube link I'll I'll we'll
tweet it out we're going to Tweet out
the link
so you guys can go find it but again if
you're on Facebook or if you're on
YouTube or you're on Twitch it will be
broadcast live same time same place noon
Eastern is when our commentary will
start we will do an hour of commentary
before the hearing the hearings have
been pretty much on time
they don't delay they're pretty prompt
Benny Thompson and and Liz Cheney do not
[ __ ] around when it comes to being on
time so my guess is is it will be one
Eastern on the dot is when the hearing
will start unless there are some
complications maybe they'll run over
but I would guess that it will start on
time so you be on time at noon to hear
our great panel we'll have Jessica
Denson uh politics girl Lee McGowan uh
Midas Mighty favorite Texas Paul
ah we're gonna have Dr Rachel bittick
offer the my zealous Brothers Gabe
Sanchez and me hosting the Tony Michaels
for the January 6th select hearing
coverage of season two of treason
Hunters
so don't forget tomorrow to go same time
same place and also I want to tell you
again I'm going to make this deal for
you everyone loves this hoodie the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty the Liberty hoodie
I'll make a deal with you
just give me a little bit of time and
I'll go over to the store
and I will post a zip up Hoodie the same
design that you see here on the screen
we're gonna put it in uh a couple
different colors
and I will post the zip up hoodie on the
smart store
just give me an hour or two or so and
I'll get it up there so go to
store.thetonymichaels.com go to
store.thetonymichaels.com to get your
pullover or soon to be your zip up
Hoodie be watching uh social media
Twitter uh Instagram the books of face
that's why you probably want to go
follow me over on Facebook follow me on
Facebook if you haven't already because
I'll be posting over there when I get
that zip up Hoodie
so if you're on Facebook and you want an
opportunity to get the zip up Hoodie as
soon as possible make sure to go follow
me at meet Tony Michaels on Facebook
also you can get your T-shirt the
freedom to oppress the rights to the
people it's not Liberty right now as we
speak it is up there
folks best audience in the world thanks
for joining me today on the Johnny
Michaels podcast same time same place
tomorrow remember tomorrow's the hearing
it's gonna be a banger it's gonna be a
banger Surfside [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon